at e3 a few weeks ago Todd Howard took
the stage to talk about fallout 76 the
game had been announced one week earlier
with a brief teaser trailer set to John
Denver's crooning tones but but that's
days press conference offered actual
concrete details we now know 76 will be
focused on multiplayer survival we know
it will be set in West Virginia and we
know it will emphasize settlement
building a system Bethesda Game Studios
established in 2015's fallout 4 as I
watched Todd promote his team's game and
marveled at the craftsmanship of that
sick leather jacket something occurred
to me I had only ever put 20 hours into
fallout 4 as with any of bgs is
open-world titles this is only a drop in
a massive bucket I hadn't reached the
level cap or played any of the
expansions or even completed the main
storyline
so I've considered myself a fallout fan
for a long time fallout 3 is one of my
favorite games and I absolutely adore
what obsidian did with Fallout New Vegas
I even went back to the first two titles
which have an age that well to see what
interplay in black I'll did to get the
series off the ground but in 2015 I
bounced off of fallout 4 maybe it was
the packed schedule of fall releases or
the numerous other games I was reviewing
for work purposes but for whatever
reason I spent a few fleeting days with
fallout 4 and quickly moved on so now
with all the excitement surrounding the
upcoming fallout entry and a brief lull
in this year's major titles I decided to
retrace my footsteps to give fallout 4
another shot to not only see what I've
been missing out on but to investigate
why such a huge entry in one of my
favorite series failed to grab me almost
three years ago
[Music]
only one hour into my new play through i
remember just how much fallout4
overwhelmed me in the first place after
emerging from vault 111 returning to my
home in sanctuary hills and fighting
through Concord with the Minutemen I
rediscovered the game's crafting system
this includes everything from modular
weapon upgrades to numerous armor
combinations perk requirements to outfit
enhancements even power armors relegated
to its own crafting tree and drastically
changes combat when you Don it as
someone who wore Fallout 3's t51 B
Armour religiously it took me a while to
think of the exosuits more as vehicles
than just outfits and of course none of
this is to mention fallout 4 is divisive
workshops if one feature serves as a
microcosm for Fallout 4 it's this a
system that allows you to construct and
modify your own wasteland outposts
complete with resources to manage and
citizens to care for you not only build
your own house but an entire town if you
devote time to creating numerous
settlements they'll eventually spread
throughout the Commonwealth three years
ago these elements were a major
deterrent for me they felt like
minecraft Lite tacked onto a game that
didn't need it to me the fallout world
has always been about wandering
scavenging living the life of a nomad in
a dangerous American hellscape to settle
down meant to wither to focus on
specific plots of land meant to ignore
the very freedom that made Bethesda's
open-world so appealing in the first
place but replaying fallout 4 in the
wake of community mods workshop DLC
packs and an array of amazing YouTube
videos about to give the settlement
aspect a little more time and in doing
so I fell in love with it the controls
and UI took a while to master especially
considering I was playing on ps4 as I
owned all of the DLC on this platform
but once I got the hang of menu
navigation there was no looking back I
bolstered my defenses I restored power
to my living quarters I even set up a
quaint little diner where greatful
patrons can relax after a hard day's
work rebuilding these camps encourages
creativity on its own but also does a
stellar job of feeding into the rest of
the game in order to create you have to
scavenge in order to scavenge you have
to explore and while exploring a
dangerous wasteland you'll likely get
into a firefight or two which then
yields more material
for crafting and that brings you right
back to your hideouts to store your best
loot fallout 4 settlements are the glue
that holds these various mechanics
together and I can't imagine the game
without them it's good to see artillery
here again to dig a little deeper this
focus on post-apocalyptic domestication
also supports Fallout 4s narrative while
earlier Fallout games told stories of
reconstruction but as does newest entry
places the idea at the heart of things
in fact most of the games role-playing
which I'll get to shortly centers around
one major question what do you want the
wasteland to be for instance you can
rebuild the Minutemen the wastelands
protective militia you liberate farms
and defend drive-in theaters you
increase the group's influence over the
Commonwealth until you retake the old
fortress itself reinforcing the castle
with artillery storefronts and crops
alternatively you could aid the railroad
a covert organization that smuggles
synths to freedom away from the
totalitarian aims of the corporate
Institute as with the Minutemen you
establish settlements in order to expand
the railroad network by constructing
outposts you actively grow the group's
reach as you might imagine I was
borderline shocked to learn that the
workshops were almost cut during
development several times
according to no clips history of
bethesda video the team saw it as
ancillary to the overall experience an
ambitious endeavor that could have
easily been abandoned I'm glad it wasn't
it fosters my attachment to the
Commonwealth wasteland serving a
narrative purpose but also giving me
opportunities to put my own mark on the
surroundings fallout 4s DLC doubled down
on the workshops not only other upgrades
to your furniture structures and
defenses but also a whole story based
expansion in Nuka world which allows you
to help Raider gangs in their bid for
dominance the DLC lets you build a
Raider Empire complete with its own
settlements and hideouts it would have
made more sense to include this in the
base game fleshing out another faction
in Fallout 4s role-playing framework but
nevertheless illustrates Bethesda's
confidence in their crafting system
really my altered perception of the
workshop system reflects my newfound
appreciation for Fallout 4 as a whole
looking back on it three years later
allows me to place it in a new context
with more details about fallout 76
I can see fallout 4 as part of a gradual
evolution that spans multiple developers
interplay and black isle may have began
the series as role-playing games but
since the 2008 release of Fallout 3
they've become something different
open-world shooters with RPG elements
that's not to say you can't really role
play in these games there are always
ample opportunities to create a
character and stick to that persona new
vegas in particular encourages you to
build a framework of morals and
motivations and pushes you through its
narrative with somewhat difficult
choices but by and large bethesda has
pushed role-playing to the background
making more room for explorations
survival and combat in the process
following the series from fallout 3 to
the upcoming fallout 76 you can see the
developer increasingly focus on these
three areas they improve crafting and
combat drastically in Fallout 4 they
subsequently added survival mode to make
the game more difficult
almost every upgradable perk is geared
toward fighting or crafting and with
fallout 76 their marketing is stressing
survival crafting and exploration over
anything else any mentions of
role-playing seem to arise as an
afterthought placed in this evolutionary
context I think fallout 4 is much much
better than I originally gave it credit
for
yes it's rife with bugs and on consoles
the framerate drops low enough to still
warrant a mention three years and
numerous updates later
there are also myriad problems when the
narrative and I'm about to get to those
but consider 76 is increased focus on
multiplayer and survival by all accounts
Bethesda should be running a huge risk
of alienating long-term players such as
myself but not only does fallout 4
convinced me that fallout 76 can fit
logically into the series evolution it
actively has me excited for it and I say
this as someone who puts past Fallout
games on an unreasonably high pedestal
which is all to say that now I can
accept fallout 4 for what it is and not
what I want it to be I can sit back
relax and enjoy the way it pushes me
between
flourishing combat scavenging and
crafting I can take my time with the
workshop system expanding my factions
across the Commonwealth I can ignore the
main storyline in favor of finding my
own emergent anecdotes
well almost my biggest problem with
fallout 4 is the way Bethesda struggled
to tie its Golden Path and narrative
into its side quests whenever possible
I appreciate the team's attempts to do
so and it's a problem almost every open
world game shares but it feels as if
Bethesda tried to more fallout 4 into a
hardcore RPG in the 11th hour the story
asks you to take sides in a conflict
between the brotherhood of steel the
corporate Institute and the
aforementioned railroad balancing the
values and goals of each organization
for this playthrough I sided with the
railroad opting to help synths escape to
freedom whenever possible
I loved the Sutter fuge involved I love
how clandestine each mission feels I
love going behind the backs of the
Institute and the Brotherhood pulling
strings to steer matters toward our
righteous goal of liberty and justice
for all
the problem is each factions motivations
don't always clash in a logical way
often times I would make a decision sure
I was pissing off another group but upon
returning to its headquarters I was
welcomed with open arms in other cases I
would stand on the precipice of a
seemingly minor decision only to have
the game tell me I was about to ally
innate a faction entirely it was in
these moments that fallout 4 tried to
take too much control away from me the
player rather than showing me how my
actions would affect the outcome get
outed to tell me instead had Bethesda
found smoother ways to draw me toward
the main story beats and more intuitive
manners to pit various factions against
each other my enjoyment may have carried
into every aspect of this sandbox as it
stands now fallout 4 feels like two
separate games a very poor RPG and a
fantastic open-world shooter but when
the latter is so fantastic it's kind of
hard to complain there's exceptional
balance on display here in terms of
scope bgs is created not just an
engrossing world but an abundance of
amazing levels placed within that world
spending time in nuclear world's
amusement park reminded me of a metaphor
one of my editors used to use if you're
designing a theme park not only do you
have to select the best rollercoasters
possible you have to arrange them in a
pleasing way
in other words balance the pieces as
well as the path tying them all together
my editor was talking about sentence
structure and article flow but I think
it works here too it was 20 hours into
my playthrough I'm a southwest corner of
the map when I really knew fallout 4 had
nailed that balance I was in the glowing
sea where a new kit Massachusetts 200
years prior radiation levels were
critical supplies were scarce I was
vulnerable and I was having a blast I
came across a cave with power armor and
a few welcome supplies shortly before
wading into a thriving nest of lethal
radscorpions there were no RPG elements
or major story beats just a dangerous
world and the threat of death around
every corner
this was fallout 4 at its best I'll be
honest when I set out to replay fallout
4 I thought I would see it as I always
have a game whose reach far exceeds its
grasp a game with more ambition that can
handle resting in a sort of purgatory
before whatever comes next
[Music]
No
but now 75 hours and 5 DLCs later I
sincerely want to keep playing parts of
its design do feel very stagnant and it
doesn't do anything to revolutionize
open worlds and as with any bgs game it
is technically flawed to say the least
but in many ways it is the pinnacle of
what a fallout game can be a dangerous
world frozen in time whose every corner
is worth exploring
[Music]
they read the girl
[Music]